Good morning John.
I wrote this song after we went on tour because people kept asking me a question
that I didn't have an answer to and this song is my answer to that question.
♫ There's somethin' happenin' on the internet and I don't really get it. ♫
♫ Once again I'll have to say "I'm not into that" but I'm sure that I'll regret it. ♫
♫ 'Cuz I know thousands of people never cared about anything more.  ♫
♫ They've spent the last six months makin' tumblrs, fanfics, and bulletin boards. ♫
♫ And I think all that excitement is great. ♫
♫ But when they ask I have no choice. I still have to say... ♫
♫ That I don't have a favorite pony, 'cuz I've never seen that show. ♫
♫ And I don't have a favorite pony, 'cuz I'm 31 years old. ♫
♫ And I don't have a favorite pony, 'cuz I'm a self-respecting dude. ♫
♫ And I don't have a favorite pony 'cuz I... ♫
♫ I just can't... ♫
♫ choooooose! ♫
♫ Well, Dash the Pegasus has rainbow hair and the cutest cutie mark. ♫
♫ And Apple Jack is the strongest mare, always working so hard. ♫
♫ And Flutter Shy has totally got that Marilyn vibe goin' on, ♫
♫ but when it comes to the beauty prize, oh Rarity's already won. ♫
♫ And Pinky Pies' excitement could fuel a jet plane. ♫
♫ But Twilight's the nerdiest, and that goes a long way. ♫
♫ But I don't have a favorite pony, 'cuz I've never seen that show. ♫
♫ And I don't have a favorite pony, 'cuz I'm 30 freakin' 1 years old. ♫
♫ And I don't have a favorite pony 'cuz I'm a self-respecting dude. ♫
♫ And I don't have a favorite pony, 'cuz I just can't choose. ♫
♫ Well my goal is to make this a better planet and I don't take that lightly. ♫
♫ I should be working my butt off all day, damn it, with any luck I might be. ♫
♫ But it's equally probable that instead of changing the world, ♫
♫ I spent the last 6 hours watching a cartoon made for little girls. ♫
♫ Oh, battles in the real world are so complexly won. ♫
♫ It's all so much simpler in Equestria. ♫
♫ But I don't have a favorite pony. I don't have one even though ♫
♫ I've spent the whole day tryin' to pick by watchin' all the episodes. ♫
♫ I don't have a favorite pony, 'cuz I'm a self respecting guy, ♫
♫ and I don't have a favorite pony 'cuz I... ♫
♫ I like ♫
♫ Spike! ♫
Thank you Michael Aranda, of course, for doing the effects.
And also to the people who put together a bunch of green screen ponies.
Woooh! Green screen ponies!
Links to their channel. Well done.
I'm at LeakyCon right now. I filmed this in the past.
But I'm not gonna talk about it 'cuz you know if you're watching this you're either there or you're not.
But what I am gonna talk about, 'cuz John maybe you aren't as excited about this as I am,
is the Evil Baby Orphanage card game Kickstarter.
I'm a tabletop card game kind of guy and I am unashamed of that.
My original Nerdfighters song was about Magic: The Gathering, you remember?
You probably don't; it was a long time ago. And you may not thus remember the Evil Baby Orphanage.
But if you don't, it was an idea that John and I conceived in order to escape the conundrum of whether or not
to kill baby Hitler if you had the chance. 'Cuz if you have the chance to kill him you also have the chance to
abduct him and bring him to an Evil Baby Orphanage.
Well, the very talented people at Weird Games got their hands on this idea and when I saw it on Kickstarter
I was like "Hey guys. Guys. Guys. Guys, can I? Can I help? Can I help? Guys, can I help?"
So they gave me a look at the whole game. It's basically like you have to collect babies to get mischief points
and you need to get more mischief points and eventually you win.
But there are a bunch of mechanics where babies that have more mischief points get, like, passed
from Time Nanny to Time Nanny, also you're a Time Nanny.
And at $50,000, they're going to do a Nerdfighter expansion which will include John and me as Time Nannies.
You will be able to play as us!
But you only get that and the other expansion perks, coloring book stuff, if you pledge more than $40, so remember that.
And if you're seeing this video after the Kickstarter ends, it's ending very soon, like 2 or 3 days, don't fret!
The game will be available for sale at your local game stores, and probably at DFTBA.com.
John! I will see you right now, because you're at LeakyCon too.
Bye.
♫ I don't have a favorite pony, 'cuz I've never seen that show. ♫
♫ And I don't have a favorite pony, ' cuz I'm 31 years old. ♫
♫ And I don't have a favorite pony, 'cuz I'm a self-respecting dude. ♫
♫ And I don't have a favorite pony, 'cuz I... ♫
♫ I just can't chose! ♫